black holes are dark matter devouring
balls of gravity
most of them are so far away that we
don't need to worry about them but not
this one
meet Gaia bh1 this enormous black hole
sits right outside our solar system
more specifically 1600 light years away
from us now that might sound like a huge
distance but it's way closer than any
other black hole on record
what's worse we didn't even know about
it until now
despite Gaia bh1 being 10 times more
massive than our sun we couldn't see it
scientists usually discover these
monstrosities by spotting the gas that a
black hole feeds on
these hungry Giants are called feeding
black holes
only Gaia bh1 isn't anything like that
this black hole is dormant
hides in the darkness patiently waiting
for the Galaxy to throw at some Cosmic
matter to Feast on
but there's one thing that gave away
gaia's presence
you see most star systems in the
universe are binary that means they have
not one but two stars orbiting each
other
our black hole neighbor is also part of
a binary star system except instead of
two stars this system has one star and
one black hole
yeah Gaia bh1 was disguising itself as a
star
but even though this monstrosity doesn't
feed on any gas or matter yet it still
couldn't help but jiggle its star
counterpart a little
yeah good try Gaia but we still caught
you
out there in space there are black holes
a lot scarier than Gaia bh1
and some are so bizarre that they
shouldn't even exist
a team of scientists discovered an
unbelievable black hole and gave it the
melodic name lb1
the weird thing about this black hole is
that it's just too massive to be true
okay let's get some facts straight we
know of two types of black holes
Stellar black holes are what massive
stars become when they die
they're everywhere in the universe Even
in our Milky Way galaxy there could be
as many as one billion of them lurking
around
[Music]
can be between 10 and 24 times as
massive as our sun
the other type of black holes are super
massive ones
these enormities sit at the center of
almost every Galaxy including our own
we don't really know how they form but
we do know that they're unimaginably
gigantic
billions of times more massive than our
sun
but lb1 doesn't fit either of these
types
at 70 solar masses it's too enormous to
be a stellar black hole yet it's too
tiny to be a supermassive one
scientists were scratching their heads
trying to explain this phenomenon
some theorize that it might not be a
single black hole but two black holes
orbiting each other
others guessed that lb1 was born of a
gigantic star that was still in the
middle of becoming a black hole
well the answer was simpler than we
thought lb1 isn't a black hole at all
it's an optical illusion caused by two
rare Stars orbiting each other it's a
unique star system to stargaze
but when scientists said they found an
improbable black hole well they were
wrong
but please how could you blame them
it's pretty hard to study an object 15
000 light years away
mistakes happen
the good news is that lb1 didn't upend
our understanding of black holes after
all
now that doesn't mean that black holes
can't blow your mind
remember the one at the center of the
Milky Way yeah it's called Sagittarius A
star and it's as massive as four and a
half Million Suns
but there's always a bigger fish in the
universe
Sagittarius A star might be the most
massive monster lurking in our galaxy
but it's not even close to some of the
really big players out there like tons
this black hole is devouring matter 10
billion light years away from us it's as
bright as
140 trillion Suns the so bright that it
outshines its own Galaxy
and it's Mass
yeah 66 billion times that of our sun
yeah that's right 66 billion
tons 618 is horrifyingly big
when scientists discovered it they began
to wonder if even more massive black
holes were possible
of course the name supermassive wouldn't
do bigger black holes any justice so
astronomers came up with a cool name for
them too
stupendously large black holes or slabs
yeah and then they found one
move over ton 618 there's a new
gargantuan black hole in town
this stupendously large monstrosity sits
at the center of Phoenix a Galaxy around
eight and a half billion light years
away from us
it's almost impossible to imagine how
enormous this thing is
scientists think it has a mass of 100
billion Suns
that's more massive than some galaxies
out there
and it won't stop growing
The Event Horizon of this black hole at
the center of Phoenix a is unimaginably
huge too
it has a diameter of about 100 times the
distance between the Sun and Pluto
if you jumped on a SpaceX Starship and
tried to fly across this black hole it
would take you 2500 years to complete
that Journey
yeah we're lucky that this monstrous
slab is so far away from us that we
don't have to worry about it swallowing
our solar system whole
but there are two more supermassive
black holes very close to Earth
and they're on a collision course with
each other
okay when I say very close to Earth I
mean 500 million light years away from
us but still closer than a lot of the
other scary things out there
seriously though we don't know what
exactly happens when two supermassive
black holes collide
we've never observed a full merger of
supermassive Giants
scientists think that they'll dance
around each other for about 200 million
years before finally becoming one
but this would be a violent marriage
as the black holes spiral together
they'll send enormous gravitational
waves through space
waves so big that will be able to detect
them from our planetary neighborhood
but that's not the scary part
mergers like that happen all the time
and right now the Milky Way is on a
collision course with the Andromeda
Galaxy
when our two galaxies become one what
will happen to the super massive black
holes at their centers
will they merge to
would an event like this tear everything
in its vicinity to shreds
yeah I bet that's what keeps astronomers
up at night
yeah our galaxy is doomed but how
exactly will this world-ending scenario
go down
you know what I'll leave that story
for another
what if